R E,FLLOT OFLL
TO K FORCEE EVASE ACON
NEAR A
BUSINESS J
A FLIGLET HURT
GER, SEEN N THE
SHWASIT AFTEE E INJURED T WH BA
THE PLANE ASCENDED.
BEE
GOT S
CLOSE TOGETHER.
MANY  FAI
SAFE, FAIL SE,OMAUTI
MANS INVOLVED ANC
>> TT'G QUEST
POINT. INVGA
LAY OUT EXACTLYS UTKNOW
AB FEET , WHEN LY THE IFFROM FO
FROM A T EDTH FIC COL ED THE P
UND OVER OAN
FEEF NO GULF STREAMSE TRAFT
ILS, FH, B
, ABOUT TWO AND A LYING ALTITU E
DISTANCE, BUT -- Y SOUND LOOK G
ACTIONS,LANE WENT , NOTINUTES
UP, THN, AND
E A          LLEGIANT PIL
MAUV DRAMATIC ENOUGH
ATN BACK TO
FORTALE SO PERSON
COULD L  THAT  INCID
THIS, A NDS IN
ANUREAOUT IT WIT.REALLY RARE. U.
E T HS IN  LIKE BE
THE AIAND ON THE
Y E
MISSES HAPPENING MORN?
>> THAT'S BEEN THEVE T YWE HAVD
SECRETY  BUTTIGIEG TK Y IN THE
NE PLANE
THTING ORUNWAY.
FAA ,
AIR TRAFFIC CONTROL
THEY HELTHY SUMMITIER IN TS ANDS
ADD N GUIDER R AFC CO
AN
TO TRY TOE T AIC
HAT THEYTAKES, WE DOVE CLOSE CA
EXPERTS AND S IN THIS
FIELD TOUTHEETURES SAFETY TRA RN
NOT HAD A CONFIRMED
ADNIA YEAR NOW.
PRESIDENT BIDETR ADMINISTRATOR
RE SCRUTINANSO
E  QUESTOU LOO ACI THIS AS TET Y
RECORD IN PLE. WTRANSPORTATION L
THEY WANREGA CTHANKS SMU, WHAT
WHS  B
FO
I'M GLAD YE  O
ARE O
FIT  TS Y MOVE OUTE WA
THISTH>>ELL, AT THAT TIME WE TH
ILL ARBEEN THROUHAT.BUT WHEN HM
ACTUALLYG TO MISS THE
OTHER AIRPLANE, IT W LIK
HAASNSIFIED ALL THAT FEA
THWAAD TO GO UD DOWNTO MISE O TE
TH WD TOO,  WAY?T. WAE REACTIONY
>> PEOD CRYI, YOU PRAYING.EVERYD
TO LOOK OUTSIDE ATHAT WAS OUND .
ATTENDANT WHS THROG
THIS.
AT YEE WELL, WHEN I --ER IED OVI
TWFL ATTENDANTRE
STAYED ON THHEN O G THE O
SAID, OH
FOR ABOUT FIVE MINES WHEY WERE U
AND MOERL
PROFESSIONALS ONH  EVENTLLE AND
FL ATTENDANT.
>> AND, WERE TO FIND A
CARE OF HADDER       O
WHO WENT BAC
THEY DIDHES  IAS ONLTH
E BEEN ON A PLANE, S. YES.
ARW AN T OF ALL, I  YOU'RE WELL
THN NG>> I'M DOING A LOTETR.IT N
YO TIN THE BACK OF YOUHERE
THAT THE THINGOUOST WENT T ATVE
EN I WO  IT T WHERULD ACTUALLY
MPAC
L GET BACKA PLE SOME DAY? THAT'T
PLANE, BUT IAN TELL  I
T
IN ALLEGIANT.
APOLOGIZE?
>> $10HEFO REAL COMMUNICATION WH
ID- AND THEY
LIUT WHAT HAPPENED.>>Y .
HOW?
WE LANDED BECAUSE WE RENTAL CABE
DIDN'T HAVE THINONND SO MY MOM
GU HELP MYILY GET A ECAUSE
THEY WERE ONT ALA YOU
THE PI AER. ON, RNROUND CA
>>ODNESS GRACIOUS, WOW'SOTAITO
STATISTICALLSTILL THE . G